[Music]
is anybody one of those people that like
uh
hates it when christmas music is playing
before thanksgiving is over no i [ __ ]
love christmas music i'm a fan i could
hear it all day i mean i could do that
[ __ ] in february bro yeah i don't i
don't particularly like it it feels
awkward
get the [ __ ] out feels weird why because
you want to play thanksgiving music yes
pilgrim beats pilgrims
pilgrimage
dude columbus greatest music what's my
playlist when i played [ __ ] call of
duty my favorite songs the the nina the
pinto santa maria
volume three
love it cornucopia beats baby
[Music]
[Laughter]
i i think christmas music should be
played i'm a traditionalist
at thanksgiving like after thanksgiving
if you if i hear last christmas on like
march
after i wipe my tears i'll like think
why is this playing now like you know um
so from thanksgiving to christmas day
is when the playlist should i think that
should be it because coast plays it
after christmas until new year's too
that's when they make the most money
yeah
post is dope i haven't listened to coast
in a while but like do they still have
love thoughts yeah i think so i love i
love i love it when latinos write in and
it's like you know thumper is saying
like
yeah
body soul you're the love of my life
she reads it with that accent
i love you forever you know it's like
you're a down ass [ __ ]
you know who it is they turned out right
in the bowl
art label had the most widest announcer
voice yeah and then he would be like we
got creeper from
chino valley
for his baby mama
remember ted bush
yes this is ted zigging bush with love
thoughts on the coast oh this is awesome
when you're a little kid you're just
peaceful yeah it is very peaceful but
they do play christmas music they let it
go on i feel like they play it after
halloween yeah yeah
that's when you tune in to coast was uh
a a u.s family from florida may receive
a 1 000 fine this year for putting the
christmas decorations up for their
family house a little too early that's
ridiculous
july if there's an hoa agreement yeah
labor day or some [ __ ]
labor day on saint patty on november 8th
the mafia family received a letter from
their local community association
threatening the fine what november 8th
is that is that too early a little too
early
if it's an hoa usually they'll say
thanksgiving and it has to be taken down
like um by new year's they're party
poopers dude [ __ ] that they're lame dude
they do um you know
uh christmas markets right
have you heard of christmas markets yeah
in europe in europe right it's a big
[ __ ] thing it's like the six to six
night market but like christmas style
that sounds fun it's fun
don't do that
are they only in europe like yeah yeah
well they celebrated really big because
it's such a religious i think it's their
thing where's one here is it like
pasadena rose or something no it's like
their chinese new year where it's like
whole month long i'm saying where is it
here we don't have it here we don't have
an equivalent but we gotta make one
imagine this right imagine it's a
christmas market like like let's say we
have a city square like we're like a
like a big [ __ ] area right and every
city does this all over europe and um
you could just walk through and they got
these like booths and these booths they
got like [ __ ] cinnamon rolls roasted
nuts [ __ ] toys roasted nuts yeah what
do you get roasted now they're so good
have you guys had roasted nuts you gotta
go to being for that [ __ ]
i want them at the rose pool
munich paris
roasted nuts chestnuts nuts all the nuts
and above i i want cranberry cider have
you ever had cranberry cider whoa dude
they got these [ __ ] cinnamon rolls
that they have on a log
and then they wrap this [ __ ] on a log
and then there's this [ __ ] old
russian grandma or whatever just [ __ ]
rotating that [ __ ] on open fire yeah and
then they and it's like cold as [ __ ]
right and you eat that but basically
they got this
but it goes it goes on past christmas it
goes in it's all winter and they should
get fined for it
set them on fire actually
yeah so so i'm like how come
they can do the christmas [ __ ] christmas
decorations past that maybe because
saint nicholas is um quiet quad
yeah that's true you know they own that
stuff he is white
he's pretty white what is he german what
is he dutch something like that it's
klaus oh that's german that was german
klaus nicholas klaus mr klaus my
neighbor across the street on the night
of halloween after the kids finished
trick-or-treating he took down his uh
halloween decorations and then
immediately replaced it with christmas
stuff and i thought that was tight but
you know what though it's like while
you're decorating because decorating
your house it takes a lot of work so
while you're doing it why are you taking
it all down you might as well just throw
up the christmas stuff i'm mad at it and
also it's his [ __ ] house why are they
finding him but you know i think it's
funny though that okay so like we're all
asian here how many of us well speak for
yourself yeah
[Laughter]
honestly how many of us put up halloween
decorations or christmas decorations i
have a kid now so we we do that every
year you do it every year now but his
wife is mexican so that's why he got him
he got invaded so you have to do feliz
navidad so it's not halloween for him
most yellow people don't put decorations
up
we don't do that so whenever i hear
stories like this i always think oh poor
white people i don't even know if
they're white but i'm just in my mind
already poor white people but you're
probably right on the money yeah right
like i bet my life on it well if they
live in one of those communities where
there's an agreed association that tells
you when to do what to do that's
probably a white neighborhood yeah
i remember one year for christmas i i i
begged my dad so we can get decorations
done because i thought it was so sick
right and then like he bought those uh
lights like we always did a christmas
tree indoors but but most yeah you're
right most asian families they don't do
the outdoor stuff right so then um he
got the he got the the little lights
that [ __ ] blink and he put it on the
[ __ ] gutter thing
and then he didn't get the long one
because he went cheap so he didn't wrap
it all the way through it went halfway
and that was it
i was [ __ ] it and we got candy canes
like like that the candy cane paper
thing put it on a [ __ ] door and he
was like voila [ __ ] and i was like
[ __ ] that ain't what i wanted dude
it's compromise man
at least your dad hung the whole thing
though what if he ran out of nails and
then they just leave it dangling you
know you know that house you know that
house there's always that house it was
like it didn't even wrap around the
whole thing it was
and it was just blinking just halfway
that was it you know what my bitch-ass
mom did i was begging her to put
christmas [ __ ] around the house right
because everyone was had like christmas
[ __ ] she said no and then when she
started hosting karaoke nights then she
got the color uh christmas lights and
put it inside where the living room is
the ambiance though yeah and i'm like
[ __ ] doesn't even serve the
purpose not for christmas it's just for
her homies to sing and feel nice and
messy but karaoke you need the light
because for yellow people karaoke is way
more valuable than christmas
like year-round you know that's year
round you could do karaoke yeah any time
of the day any night no one will
complain they'll be like oh look at that
yellow family doing karaoke in march
no one's gonna say that's crazy no one's
gonna get a fine for that yeah but
christmas lights hey so you guys
wouldn't be feel awkward if you were at
a karaoke night not on christmas and
someone put christmas music on the
playlist that's that's weird that's
weird that's weirder than just hearing
it see bart would think that's tight i
can enjoy christmas at any time you
can't you can you can right it's the
best so basically if we all went to
karaoke and silent night came on you
guys would turn it into a duet [ __ ] yeah
knowing that it was making somebody
uncomfortable absolutely well that's a
different pleasure yeah
we'll get our own we'll get our own room
did you know mariah carey when she tours
uh she has to perform her christmas song
that
because they just like the song they
just love it like all i want for
christmas is you like well she's always
performing all year round when she
internationally talks it's her biggest
track is that top five christmas songs
of all time it's top one number one so
she's like in hot ass dubai in the
middle of summer
singing for christmas like we'll make it
snow i was in malaysia and singapore
during during like uh right before
christmas and it's like 85 degrees with
95 humidity in both those countries
right
and then uh it's hot obviously and
sweaty outside as soon as you walk into
their glorious palatial malls all you
see is christmas decorations and there's
christmas songs playing i had never
heard of and i'm like and this is a
muslim country yeah but they're all
playing christmas songs about baby jesus
yeah and that's the strangest thing
because it's hot yeah and then there's
christmas well that's uh australia right
yeah yeah because there's a great summer
yeah oh it's right there
so there are they're santa claus uh
they're commercials and santa claus
riding like jet skis and [ __ ] with like
sleeveless santa claus just like
sunburns and stuff because it's
mid-summer it's hot that's fine yeah
that's hot that's fun though if they do
that they're doing it wrong but that's
fun
stupid but it's fine i'm actually
spending this christmas in hawaii so
that's going to be interesting
i hear hawaiians love christmas i've
done christmas in hawaii they love it so
much same weather as regular hawaii they
have christmas decorations
yeah i heard that i hear that it's not
because they're too lazy to take it down
no no no they just love it that much i
mean because hawaiians aren't
stereotypically lazy no no not at all
not at all
it's just a different pace right right i
know yeah
i i have this great town and country
shirt that i got in hawaii it says i'm
not late i'm not late that's exactly you
know it's like no that was right next to
uh why try or try weight right why try i
didn't see a chill or something like
that frank chill yeah i would i would
have tried to i would have gone
they had a dancing santa and like all
the
santa decorations up when i went two
months ago already they're ready to go
yeah so it was that september they were
ready to go like the seven days if it's
september that means they left it up
they look brand new maybe maybe they
clean it was at a grocery store dude it
was a dancing santa
and i was like damn they just wanted to
skip thanksgiving yeah
maybe just any time the store has the
dancing stand the sales just go through
the roof yeah probably huh maybe it's
not a holiday thing it's just
straight-up marketing marketing guy
looking at a graph i know whatever
happened in this month do it again yeah
do you think people are going to slowly
stop celebrating thanksgiving as much i
don't even know if they do thanksgiving
out there
i was i was just talking to my sister
with her niece and nephew because
remember when we were in thanksgiving at
school we would [ __ ] like like make
pilgrim buckles and then like native
american indian like and then you did
the [ __ ] turkey with the you put
brown on your hand
turkey dude
we're not doing any more because it
looks like this is that [ __ ] in in with
taika did he do a hand turkey i think he
didn't have turkey yeah he did it did it
look like a turkey they're behind
you
right [ __ ] pilgrim clothes with
construction paper that's what we did
the buckles and the hats
you simulate like the dinner or the
whatever yeah and the murdering
afterwards yeah it's crazy like the real
reason they're not doing thanksgiving is
because of murdering indians but
according to him it's because the hand
turkey didn't look like a turkey that
that's why we stopped doing it i speak
for all of jk news that's why we all
don't like thanksgiving that's the main
reason
the turkey hands don't look turkey
enough lack of realism it's not because
it's not because white people took a
native american's land it's because the
hand turkey doesn't look like it's very
good it's a land turkey
[Music]
you